training your rotational strength
training in the transverse plane should
be non-negotiable this is movement an
entire plane in real life you don't only
move in the frontal or the sagittal
plane you need to twist your body
whether you're throwing a ball or
javelin throwing a punch or a kick or
grappling rotation is extremely
important
however a lot of training programs don't
include anything for rotation if you're
following a conventional bodybuilding
program or powerlifting program there's
a good chance you aren't training your
rotational strength at all and if you
are you might not be doing enough so
today i'm going to talk you through a
bunch of different rotational exercises
you can do and why they're so important
and as it would happen somebody has left
some bands here attached to this tree
which could come in handy
[Music]
and once again today i'm joined by grant
stephens what's up guys he's going to
help me get some more dynamic shots do
some training and if you are interested
in training and martial arts and
lifestyle then check out his channel
i'll put a link in the description down
below loads of really awesome stuff
there if you are a little bit of out of
the curve and you're already doing some
training for your rotational strength
then chuck hang on wait a second
better so if you are a bit ahead of the
curve and you're ready to do some
training for your rotational strength
then chances are one of the moves you
might be using is the pilot press if
you're not familiar with it essentially
what you're going to do is take a band
or a cable you're going to step a little
bit away so there's some tension
and then you're going to hold it close
to your body like so facing in the same
direction and then push it outwards from
your body basically what happens here is
that as the band as the
handle gets further away from your body
it increases the torque and what you
have to do is fight the rotational force
which is trying to twist you that way
that makes this an anti-rotation
movement
about core stability
this becomes really useful if you're
trying to prevent someone from twisting
you to the ground or just performing a
bunch of different calisthenics
movements like a one-armed push-up
obviously you need to train it on both
sides like so
and this is a really useful tool to
include in your arsenal
so another great movement for
anti-rotational stability is the
one-armed push-up this is a slightly
more difficult
option and here basically what you're
doing is you're trying to push yourself
up so you get all the benefits of a
push-up you're putting more weight onto
one side so it's a great way to load one
peck and one tricep more but at the same
time trying to prevent gravity from
pulling that other shoulder down towards
the ground and twisting your body so it
is an anti-rotation movement
when you perform this you want to make
sure you've got your shoulder depressed
as much as possible
lower to the ground
and push up
so now you might already be doing those
movements and if that's all you're doing
for your rotational strength and it's
certainly better than nothing and it is
a useful thing that should definitely
include however it's not enough on its
own you can't just do a couple of
exercises for your entire plane of
motion i think that's going to cover
everything it's like saying well i'm
doing squats that's all i need for the
sagittal plane it just doesn't work like
that so when you perform movements like
this the very nature of an anti-rotation
movement is isometric so you're only
strengthening yourself in that one
position with a little bit of spillover
but there's no range of motion you need
some fully twisting movements as well if
you're gonna be able to develop strength
from every angle and really tap into as
much power as possible in those
positions this is where some other
movements come in and some other things
you might already be doing include
things like russian twists and twisting
sit-ups these are also great exercises
and you should of course be doing them
but they have their limitations as well
first of all there's not that much
resistance they're not that explosive so
you're building strength endurance and
improving your proprioception but you're
not building a lot of strength and
explosiveness in those ranges at the
same time you're only rotating your core
because rotation doesn't just mean core
rotation rotating your waist it also
means hips when you rotate your hips and
your core together that's when you
develop real power when you throw a
punch when you throw a ball when you're
moving you need to be able to remove
these things at the same time and you
need to be able to ground yourself and
drive yourself off the ground to develop
that power so we need to train this but
i'm not saying that russian twists
aren't useful because being able to also
just move your upper torso is useful in
order to learn that proprioception a lot
of us are very tight we don't rotate
much at all in our daily lives and as
such we forget how to move those parts
of our body independently you might have
tight ql muscles for example which can
limit movement in this range and it's
also just feeling yourself moving in
that area and so obviously you might
also want to do some targeted mobility
work for the thoracic spine rotation in
particular and you can do something here
like the grab reach i've talked about
before basically just get into the crab
position but then reach over and behind
that's perfect because you're getting in
that rotation but also some lateral
flexion for the spine and some extension
as well
so like i say you need to be able to
rotate the core on its own but you also
need to be able to take the core with
the hips to really drive power through
your body if you were throwing a hook
for example you wouldn't twist just your
upper body you'd be able to develop
barely any power that way you want to
throw the hips in as well and the same
thing goes if you're throwing a ball
throwing a regular cross or really
engaging in a whole range of motions
fortunately there's lots of ways that we
can train this too let's say when you're
punching and kicking for example you
need to rotate through the hips and
through the core and that's actually a
great way to practice this i've said
this before even if you're not planning
on being a fighter not interested in
martial arts throwing punches and kicks
and doing shadow boxing and heavy bag
work is a fantastic workout not just for
the metcon but also for proprioception
for building rotational strength and
explosiveness so i highly recommend you
incorporate this in your training at the
same time there's a bunch of other
things you can do for example one of my
favorites is the medical slam so you've
got the rotational slam you've got the
shot put through anything that involves
twisting the body as you throw the ball
and you're going to drive through and
really build that ballistic power this
also works the serape effect which i've
talked about in the past which is the
kind of sling of muscles that you engage
when you use movements like a throw and
it's one of the most powerful movements
that the human body can perform so it's
a fantastic thing to be training
so when you're throwing the med ball
like that you want to really focus on
not just generating power through your
core but through your hips as well
really talking the hips and pushing
through the foot in the same manner
another way we can train this
is with a club bell or an indian club
there's tons of movements that are
fantastic for training in the transverse
plane one of my favorite being the atlas
swing and here you're going to take the
club on one side you're going to swing
it horizontally across your body
like so
as you do this you're transitioning the
weight from one foot to the other
and you're driving through the hips
as much
as you're driving through the core
so those movements are great if you want
to build ballistic and explosive
strength in the transverse plane but you
also want to build strength in the
transverse plane so you want to find
something where you're going to feel
resistance all the way through the
movement and we can load up the amount
of resistance a lot higher and for this
some brilliant movements you can use are
the wood chopper and the cable punch out
i'm doing it here with bands it's even
more effective with a cable because you
have a slightly more linear strength
curve but either way this challenges you
to turn through the core and the hips
but at the same time you're pulling
against a decent amount of resistance to
really build strength here
and here i'm training for a wide range
of motion and i can really add as much
resistance
as i want
and so the cable or band punch out is
basically like a band or cable press but
the difference is that you're using a
staggered stance and then you're going
to again twist
through the hips at the same time as
extending the fist obviously this isn't
going to build that looseness and the
snapping power you want for a punch but
it is going to build that stable base of
strength from which to draw upon through
that range of motion and focusing on all
those muscles and even if you're not a
fighter once again you need strength
here this is a great way to build it and
to add
some real resistance there as well
so there's some exercises and some ideas
for training your rotational strength
and the key here is to use a combination
of these things as usual so you want to
train anti-rotation you want to train
through a wide range of motion you want
to train just the core on its own you
want to train the core with the hips you
want strength you want ballistic
strength and you want explosiveness if
you do all that you'll have a fantastic
core it's extremely powerful
thank you so much for watching this one
guys let me know in the comments down
below what you do to train your core a
huge thank you to grant stevens for
coming and filming again today be sure
to check out his channel if you want
martial arts and training tips i'll
leave a link to that description down
below as usual if you like training that
focuses not just on building strength
and aesthetics but all around mobility
and performance even brain training then
check out my ebook and training program
super functional training there's a
discount on and a link in the
description down below thank you so much
for watching this one guys please like
and share it around if you would that
helps me out immensely and i'll see you
next time thanks for watching
and bye for now
i